these disruptions are temporary
economists call all these things
transitory effects supply bottlenecks
have developed
that have caused inflation i believe
that they're transitory their
expectation is that these inflation
rises will be transitory transitory a
word no one knows that's the
bi-administration's favorite word now
they've spent months trying to convince
us that inflation will just go away
but tell that to california where people
are paying record high gas prices
and like a bunch of brain dead zombies
the media is rushing to joe biden's
defense looking to blame anybody but joe
for our supply chain problems while
nobody likes to pay more on average we
have the money to do so household
savings hit a record high over the
pendant we talked to a lot of truck
drivers this is again an industry
populated um by a lot of white men over
the age of 55. um this group of people
overwhelmingly voted for trump joe
biden's getting the blame for things he
doesn't control gas prices blame the
previous administration
see somehow this is all trump's fault or
his supporters fault or even your fault
for just having saved a little bit of
doubt but it's really anybody but joe's
fault and like every other issue they've
cried about over the last few years the
media's flat out wrong
remember these are the same people who
defamed the covington catholic kids
insisted there was no evidence to the
wuhan lab leak theory claimed hunter
biden's laptop was russian
disinformation and helped crooked
hillary spread actual disinformation
through the steele dossier maybe this is
why no one trusts the liberal media
anymore cnn has just seen a 76 drop in
viewership just since january msnbc
isn't that far behind with a 61
percentage drop
and sleepy joe biden is doing even worse
over the weekend his approval ratings
took another hit
washington post and abc have them at 41
usa today has them down at 38
this is what happens when the left
ignores issues facing real americans the
people just tune them out that's why no
one's watching them and millions of you
have turned to us
joining me now mike rowe narrator and
executive producer of how america works
on fox business which you can check out
tonight all right we've saved so much
cash we just have like maybe they're
talking about bitcoin where everyone's
so rich from bitcoin we can afford you
know 30 dollar bananas what's transitory
transit do you know what that word means
yeah you remember that line and a
princess bride when diego montoya says
you keep using that word i do not think
it means what you think it means exactly
yeah it's not a word i would use if i
was a politician the thing that's making
people crazy i think you know i mean in
life if somebody tells you something
and then does something and those two
things are different a rational person
will believe the thing you do not the
thing you say but now we're in a world
where people are doing things that we
can see but we're being told that that's
not happening right and when you start
to stack those things up
it's enough to make you look over your
shoulder and think you know am i being
punked right and it's just example after
example after example uh and i don't
want to run through them all no i'll run
through them i mean just off the top of
my head you have the immigration
situation seasonal uh we're going to
stay in afghanistan until we get
everybody out sure
inflation's transitory you know i'm
really focused on gas prices what have
you done about gas well how about this
one like in my lane we talk about the
skills gap yeah talk about 1.7 trillion
dollars in student loans and we talk
about 10.4 million open positions right
now and every day somebody goes to my
little facebook page and says mike no no
the skills gap is a myth it's not real
right
and for a while there like back in 2008
when i started my little foundation
because there were 2.3 million open
positions i'm like but look it's 2.3
million they're like no no it's not
that's not real
10.4 million
it's real there are millions of people
who are either lacking the skills or the
will to take advantage of the
opportunities that are on the table and
that's why i'm narrating how america
works tonight on fox business as you may
have mentioned at eight o'clock well you
also had some other good news that you
wanted to share didn't they well yeah
dirty job dirty jobs dirty jobs is
coming
uh january 2nd on discovery some people
consider this job a dirty job well i've
seen what's
no gut felt was just in here that
explains the mess
no but you're right about it's fine the
way you were talking about how the
mainstream media deceives people because
i remember you know last couple years we
had peace and prosperity wages were
rising the border was more secure there
was low crime
and the media portrayed that we were on
the brink of a civil war remember this
is 1930s germany sure now you have
you know open borders you have russia
china on the march everything's more
expensive shelves are empty and the
press is saying you know what everyone's
rich right this is all good don't worry
about it yes but there's something else
going on too and i would just say this
look you guys do a terrific job of
reporting the news and the news by
definition is 98 bad and 330 million
people watch what's happened over the
last year and a half just optically
dude it's enough to depress a hyena
right there has to be other stuff on tv
are they looking hyena is happy they're
laughing they're like laughing hyena is
in a state of constant bliss so to
depress a hyena is not an easy thing to
do okay but the optics today right my
shows feature real people doing real
jobs that are really in demand who have
prospered as a result of learning a
skill it's really simple we don't do
second takes we give an honest look like
a fly on the wall of what work looks
like and it'll make you feel better
whether you want to get your hands dirty
or not it is funny because you have all
this stuff happening in the country and
joe biden's talking about a racist
bridge or what the weather is going to
be like a hundred years from now
we don't care about what the problems
were a hundred years ago a hundred years
from now we want him to focus on the
problems today look and that's the
problem he's facing fine but as a guy
who's desperately trying to stay in his
lane desperately desperately trying
you're doing a great job i was going to
hit you with written house but oh great
maybe i'll come back tomorrow for that
what could possibly go wrong nothing
could go wrong not when you're on the
job mike rowe check them out on fox
business tonight and they just renewed
dirty jobs everything's clicking in mike
rowe's life i tell you what man it's
better to be lucky than good
thanks very much you're welcome
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else